wait for unemployment get unemployment
now
pay back unemployment just another issue
hundreds are dealing with of recent
we know many of you reached out to us
with the question
why is this happening joe mohler live
outside dieter
he's got some answers for so many
valley-wide asking that question hi joe
hey there this is another layer of
frustration for many people who lost
their jobs and need unemployment
benefits
many i spoke to say they are confused
because not only did they already wait
weeks not if not months four benefits
but now they're being asked to pay it
back one way or another
it put me owing over two thousand
dollars yolanda frazier said she was
shocked when she got a letter stating
she was overpaid unemployment benefits
it took three months to get that
overpayment letter
she says this happened because she got a
severance but that severance came after
she was already filing for unemployment
frazier reported the severance to deter
but the letter regarding our payment
came months later for
five weeks i think it was i didn't get
any payments
from fraud to severances we have come
across a number of scenarios as to why
people are being told they were overpaid
amber hansen who runs a popular
unemployment assistance facebook page
says this issue has come up a lot
a lot of people that have had seen that
mass disqualification and the
commonality with them is that it has to
do with some type of overpayment in
another state or perhaps here
hanson says she has talked to dieter
officials about this and it is being
looked into
she says it gets confusing because pua
is a federal program they could
potentially take up to 50 percent of
whatever the amount is owed or
or some type of payment arrangement
again
because we're dealing with federal and
state
laws some of them intermingle with one
another and some of them
have strict abundance by
regular unemployment compensation
statutes
frazier says she will be paying back the
two thousand dollars
but it will be taken out of her future
payments i wish there was
more help that facebook that's where i
was going
to to get try to find answers to to
questions
and now back out here live in a recent
interview we did do with dealer
officials they did explain they are
working
on more guidance for those who are
dealing with this overpayment
issue reporting live in las vegas joe
mall 8 news now